marc antoine roy met tout en place pour
accueillir les tout petits dans sa
classe d'éducation physique à l'école
sainte-marie de règles nous en côte nord
l'enseignant de 30 ans a voulu mettre
l'épaule à la roue pour contrer la
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre enseignante qui
frappe durement sa région moi c'était
pour aider les enfants puisque joueurs
c'est que les jeunes qui sortent de chez
eux trouvent un moyen de s'amuser
en faisant d'activité physique
entraîneur physique est diplômée en
techniques policières il est ce qu'on
appelle un enseignant non légalement
qualifiés marc-antoine nani brevets ni
diplôme d'enseignement
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre criant
tellement criante que le recours à ces
enseignants non qualifiés en province a
plus que doublé lors de la dernière
année scolaire selon des données
obtenues par radio-canada en dix ans il
a même explosé plus de 3400 tolérances
d'engagement ont été délivrés à des
enseignants non qualifiés en 2021 du
jamais vu ça ne constituent qu'une
infime part du nombre d'enseignants non
légalement qualifiés dans notre réseau
cette chercheuse estime qu'ils seraient
en fait dix fois plus nombreux et près
de 30000 à enseigner à nos enfants sans
avoir de diplôme en enseignement puisque
rien n'oblige les centres de services
scolaires à faire une demande de
tolérance au ministère de l'éducation
ils ont envie d'enseigner sont là par
choix donc donnons leur les moyens
de se qualifier d'abord la formation
dont ils ont besoin l'une des solutions
phares proposées par plusieurs une
formation universitaire accéléré plutôt
que les quatre années de bac actuelle si
longtemps rentrer au bureau mais
maintenant je rentre à l'école après une
maîtrise en marketing et 15 ans dans ce
métier valentine pernaut a changé de cap
l'an dernier la voilà maintenant
enseignante au primaire est possible
pour elles de se qualifier perdre un
salaire pendant quatre ans pas
envisageable dans ma famille
malheureusement mais j'ai envie de faire
ce métier c'est pour ça que je me dois
je me donne le ministre de l'éducation
jean françois roberge dit poursuivre ses
efforts pour contrer la pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre enseignante et qu'on crée
plus de place dans les programmes de
maîtrise afin de permettre aux
titulaires de bac à l'arrière de se
qualifier à titre d'enseignant mais le
ministre ne fixent toujours pas
d'échéancier à court terme
quant à marc antoine il compte
poursuivre l'enseignement tant que la
passion l'habite pour moi ces sommes à
pcc soit ma récompense c'est de voir les
jeunes s'épanouir et poursuit ses
apprentissages en continu pour améliorer
ses qualités d'enseignant ici jérôme
bergeron radio canada montréal